chef lorena garcia opened chica at the
venetian five years ago and she
continues to bring the latin american
flair to las vegas jillian had the
chance to talk to her about all the
exciting accomplishments she has done
we are taking a trip to latin america
without even having to leave the las
vegas strip i'm here at chica inside the
venetian we're about to head inside
we're talking good food good vibes and
i'm gonna go find chef lorena garcia
come on the opportunity to open here in
las vegas open up and you know a few
years ago i competed on top chef masters
and i was here at the venetian resort
competing when i saw the wall of
culinary titans i put it on my vision
board that vision came to life five
years ago when chica opened at the
venetian it was a milestone for me to
see that it was a realization of all the
i work
not looking to my neighbors but only
focusing into my work and what i wanted
to do and what i wanted to bring to the
table which is the flavor for latin
america chef lorena garcia took on a
role that was larger than just an
executive chef they asked me how do you
feel being the only one i'm like oh hold
on what do you mean i'm the only one
being the very first female executive
chef to open a restaurant on the las
vegas strip chef lorena has since
created new opportunities for her fellow
ladies so here chica you know my
workforce in the kitchen it's over 50
ladies you know doing what we do the
best in creating
executive positions for them to continue
to grow into the business so i think
that is something very important and
very close to my heart because there is
a lot that we can do continuing to
elevate the business the cuisine and the
culture i come from venezuela but i have
lived in peru in argentina i spend a lot
of time in mexico in colombia the
northern part my family lives in costa
rica you know in fact i have really a
nice coverage of what it is latin
cuisine that when you come to miami
which is what i spent my entire life
over 30 years is that the accessibility
of ingredients of peruvian cuisine for
example that i spent so much time uh you
know the chili churris the pickles the
tacos the arepas i mean you have such a
beautiful influences of ingredients and
and dishes that i wanted to bring that
culture to las vegas chica recently
underwent renovations giving it a very
energetic and vibrant vibe to match all
of their locations the heart of chica we
wanted to be
connected to that common thread right so
it is the same feeling so you know no
matter what city you're in you know that
you're a chica so yes i want to bring
you to the kitchen i want to bring you
to my line i want to make you our famous
octopus i am super super proud of this
octopus that we have super high quality
it's nice and crispy comes from the
charcoal i bathe it with a little bit of
ajiamarillo in mojo rojo and then i
serve it with blister peppers a little
bit of crispy quinoa and all of that in
a skillet with a little bit of char so
you have the smoke going on as it goes
into the restaurant so it's really
delicious
[Laughter]
it makes sense right it's amazing and
i'm a busy eater
and that is delicious
[Music]